good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us today
my name is Wayne Matten and I am joined
today by you me Lynn we all call him
Jimmy it's very important that Jimmy's
here because he is the developer of the
graph software and so he'll be answering
questions in the questions pod if you
have some questions that you want to ask
specifically of me or a Jimmy if it's
about the graph software recommend
emailing Jimmy our emails are there so
feel free to go ahead and use those and
this is what the plan is for today I'm
gonna introduce graph very briefly talk
about why was created and how it works
at a very superficial level and then
mostly do some demonstrations of how to
use graph to main functions of graph are
to identify duplicates and closely
related samples in your data and a
relatively new feature is the ability to
look at populations and determine
estimate subject ancestries within those
data sets so that's the basic plan today
everything's going to be in slides at
the end I may go to the web page web
pages and show you how some of this
works based on a CGI that the Jim Ian
and folks at DB gap have developed to
present these data okay so why was graph
created as I mentioned there there are
two main components but the original one
is essentially created to help deal with
the DB gap data in the sense that DB gap
is a huge database there's hundreds of
studies now incorporating well over a
million individuals and as you know most
G wast genome-wide Association type
studies make the assumption that the the
individuals in the study are not closely
related so one function of graph is to
act as sort of a curation tool to pick
out duplicates and very close relatives
identify those and deal with those as
you see fit for your analyses part of
the part of that process and I put these
terms here here mostly because they may
come up in later slides the subject
sample mapping pie
the pedigree files those are pretty
commonly known about files in this sort
of work and those those get used in that
first step in looking at relatedness the
second function we often call graph pop
for population was added fairly recently
and that's the function that helps to
estimate subject ancestors so basically
it deals with the problem of the
assumption of you know having
individuals that are not related you can
pick those out and it also deals with
the the issue among jiwa studies that
meant much of this data was collected on
different genotyping platforms so it
sort of normalizes that problem as well
okay so as part of the population
addition we started adding links on DB
gap pages so this is just a screenshot
of the DB gap Advanced Search page and
I'll I'll show that at the end as well
and there's a link there called
population graph and if you were to open
this this first arid study there would
also be a link within those within that
first page of the study that is called
ancestry components and those would both
take you to the same graph which would
look something like this this is a very
simplified data set here with mostly
Europeans but this is just sort of a
teaser is what we're going to talk about
later when we when we start talking
about the graph population function so
those links are appearing on more and
more of the of the studies okay so very
briefly how does graph work and this is
going to be at a very superficial level
if you have detailed questions about
this there is a publication and pilla
PLoS ONE that came out last year and the
link for that is on many of the pages
I'll show you including the software
page where you can download this
software so I highly recommend that
paper and but just to give you some
fundamental background again mostly to
introduce terms it'll be on some of the
slides a key component here in
identifying the duplicates and the
closely related subjects is a
set of pre-selected fingerprint snips so
right now there's about 10,000 I think
there may be plans to to add to that
Jimi's nodding his head yes and so those
are very carefully selected they
represent many of the common genotyping
platforms they were selected to be by
allelic and have relatively high minor
allele frequencies they were selected to
avoid linkage disequilibrium as much as
possible in other words they're they're
well separated they also happen to cover
well represent the 22 autosomes and also
there's no strand information needed in
the deficits so there are no
complimentary alleles no eighty or GC
pairs so you don't have to worry about
stranded nough signore in your data so
that's a key component and then there
are these two statistical metrics the
all genotype mismatch Dre or the AGM R
and the homozygous genotype mismatch
rate those definitions are fairly
self-explanatory there so you'll be
seeing those on some of the graphs we
look at so that's for the relatedness
aspect of graph the population component
is a bit more complicated and actually
very cool I'm not gonna be able to go
into math here because I don't
understand it that well but at a
superficial level the subjects get
clustered using genetic distances from
some reference populations and then
those clusters get projected onto a
plane and based on barycentric
coordinates you can look at the position
of those clusters and get some idea as
to where they fall relative to the
reference populations and also part of
the process is develop these statistical
metrics genetic distance one through
four and we'll look at how plotting
those in different ways can give you
different views of these planes and
almost rotate the planes so we'll be
looking at those plots and a little bit
of details would go along okay and then
one of the main questions of course is
house is going to help you
you can download the graph software and
run that locally on either your own data
set or on the DB gap data or other data
and just one possible use cases you know
in addition to trying to pick out you
know maybe some errors in your data you
can also answer questions like well are
the subjects that I'm that I'm wanting
to add to a new project have they been
represented in other studies so you want
to want to be aware of that and then
another good use is if you're submitting
data to dbgap the DB gap curators can
now send you a URL that you know they
used on the CGI that Jimmy and other
folks at DB gap developed and these
these URLs will then show you the plots
themselves so you can get some checks on
the data that you're submitting before
it's finalized and that's very helpful
in the process those links will be
similar to some of the ones that are
that are showing up on the web page okay
so where can you get this graph package
basically if you just do an internet
search for DB gap software one of the
first pages will be this page of
software you can download G zipped file
there right now this is compiled only
for gnu/linux and there's also a link
there to that paper that I was talking
about to give you more of the details on
how graph works are there any plans to
compile this on other platforms or to
make the source available okay no
immediate plans to do that but we'll see
what happens in the future so I just
wanted to give you a quick look at
what's in that package I'm not going to
run anything on the command line today
but this will give you a good idea of
what's in there so there's two very good
documents this readme on top is is
enough to get you going running this on
the command line it's pretty simple and
then the pop documentation was added
later because that describes the
population graphing function then you
have basically four programs in there to
Perl scripts to do the plotting and then
two types of graph programs so if you
to run graph pop for example pop is just
an option on that graph command line
also happen here those that set of
fingerprinting snips okay so an example
command line could be as simple as this
graph with the option plink and most of
you probably familiar with what a plink
set is but it includes these three file
types bed beam and fam so you specify
that plink set and then simply output a
table of those relationships then there
are of course other options if you need
to have a sample subject mapping file
because as your sample and subject IDs
and they differ then you can add that
and you can add a pedigree file whatever
your particular data set requires so
after you run that that first graph run
to get the output file a text alpha file
you can then plot that using one of the
Perl scripts plot graph Perl in this
case input that output from the previous
file and that will create a PNG file for
you here's just an example of what that
PNG output might look like okay so
that's enough for the command line and I
want to just jump into some results to
explain what some of these plots mean
the top row here just represents the
relatedness sort of functions and then
after looking a few of those we'll look
at some of the population scatter plots
as well so in the simplest case here
we're plotting on the x-axis the Auld
genotype mismatch rate against some
number of pairs on the y-axis in this
particular case we're looking at
duplicate samples and monozygotic twins
in other words duplicates and you can
this would be how it will come out
initially but you can adjust the number
of pairs there so if we set that number
of pairs to 50 we basically zoom in on
this graph and so you can start to pick
out some things here that would be good
to know about so for example the little
gray bit up here at the top of the
identical pairs shows you that there are
some that are not reported in this data
set and also should point out these
vertical lines here sort of
estimates of where identical would fall
out full siblings would fall out P O
stands for parent offspring and then D 2
D 3 our second degree and third degree
relatives and then on is unrelated so in
this particular data said it looks like
there's some reported you know
duplicated pairs that might actually be
first-degree relatives based on this all
genotype mismatch rate you know well
about 25 percent you should definitely
be well below 25 percent if you want to
identify something as identical or
monozygotic twin and then we also see
out here here a couple that were
reported as monozygotic twins but the
rate is very high around fifty five
percent which would indicate in fact
they're probably unrelated so that's the
sort of check said this this type of
plot can give you so again that was the
AGM are against the number of pairs you
can also plot the H M gr I'm sorry
should be H GM are on the x-axis and the
number of pairs on the other axis and
here we're looking at the full sibling
here parent-offspring second degree
third degrees so the degree of
relatedness is decreasing as you go to
the right here and if we look at that in
some detail we see that some of these
parent-offspring pairs are actually
quite a few were not reported same for
the full sibling pair pairs in so these
gray are the not reported and then looks
like there's some second second-degree
relatives that are not reported and also
out here in the unrelated it looks like
you know they thought that they were
monozygotic twins or full sibling pairs
but they're actually probably unrelated
and we can actually zoom in on that to
see that a little bit better as well so
you see the color coding for the
monozygotic twins out here probably
unrelated based on the graph
calculations okay and then if you plot
the HTM R versus the AGM R with a GMR on
the y axis then you get this sort of
scatter plot and
so here we've got parent-offspring full
sibling second degree and third degree
relatives and these ellipses here
represent where 95% calculated would
occur in this those those particular
types so we see the full sibling is is
pretty good but one good reason to do
this you can start to pick out outliers
a little easier in this this type of
plot okay so let's move on then to graph
population examples so again this is how
you can infer subject ancestry it's just
an example we'll look at some real data
here so here we've got by default what
the plot is on the x-axis the genetic
distance one gt1 and on the y-axis gd2
and so here's this plane that I was
talking about and on this vertices is
European African and lower-left East
Asian in the lower right so these are
color-coded by the by the reported
ancestry and then the positions are what
are calculated by graph so you can see
there's some mixtures in here so for
example in this region here
self-reported Hispanics and Asian
Indians are overlapped in this area and
on this axis over here Sulphurs reported
Hispanics overlapped with Africa and
backgrounds and there's a pretty clear
cluster of self-reported Asian Indians
over here so this is how it looks in
that particular plane but if you then
change the plot and I'll show you how to
do this on the web pages and put dd4 on
the x-axis then you begin to separate
out some of these populations so for
example the Hispanics are nicely
separated now from the South Asians and
also it separates these two Asian
populations a little better as well so
that's the real advantage of going to
that particular type of plot then I have
one more example of that so here we've
got a mixture for example in here of
South Asians with Hispanics this is the
gd1 versus the GT
- and if we plot that against gg4 we
begin to get a nice separation of those
so again another good example of how
plotting and using these different
metrics can help you to tease apart the
the ancestry there okay so let's go over
the web page and see if I can
demonstrate some of this so let me
escape out of this PowerPoint
presentation so I'll go over to the
Advanced Search page and here's an
example of make this a little bigger
that population graph link you click on
that then you see that plot we were
looking at before and you also have some
options over here to change what you're
looking at plot gt4 in that sort of
thing I'm not going to demonstrate any
of that right here what I wanted to show
was okay so here you have options to
change the plotting so right now this is
that HDM are plotted against the number
of pairs that we saw earlier all you
have to do do to get the scatter plot
then is click on this HTM r + AGM R
button and that will reap lot that and
that's what we saw earlier and then in
terms of the population graphs
let me go over to this one so here's one
that's where we're just looking at the
plane we've got some mixtures here maybe
you can tease that out a little better
by plotting with GD 4 on the y-axis
check that and it redraw that and you
can do things you know it depends on
your access to the to the data as to how
many options you have on the
particularly on the URLs that the
curators might send you you have access
to that data so you're gonna get more
options but if you don't have the access
you're more limited in yeah but that I
think gives you a pretty good idea of
what you can do with those plotting
functions and that was most of what I
wanted to show you were there any
questions Jimmy that came in that you
think would be appropriate for everybody
to see okay so the question is have
could graph be
unloaded on to Android so it's possible
but it hasn't been tested so that's a
good thing for us to test out any other
questions
remember there will be a document on
that materials directory and there will
be a link to materials on the courses
and webinars page as well again feel
free to email you to myself or Jimmy at
those email addresses that run the
second slide and of course for general
questions you can you can send emails to
the info address info at NCBI NLM de and
H gov thanks again for showing up and
stay tuned for upcoming webinars